hi this is Paul and this is roughraff
for Sunday where I run through the
current version of my Sunday
sermon I know people on the internet
know this but not as many people in the
church know it um so I'm I'll be heading
to Europe again in February um and one
of the events I'm very excited about is
the Gathering in gallway Christ and
culture where I'll be talking with
Martin Shaw Paul
kingsnorth uh frier Father Paul Murray
father Connor McDon and a bunch of
others
and it's you know when I think
about how my life has changed in the
last seven years did I ever imagine I
would be on the west coast of Ireland
having a conversation with two converts
to or Eastern Orthodoxy and two Roman
Catholic Friars I never would have
imagined that but I'm tremendously
excited about it I'll be staying as a as
a guest with the uh with the Friars
and I'm just very very excited about it
um you know I've I've I've spoken with
I've met Martin and Paul before I've
never met the two Roman Catholic Friars
of course I know Marcus Marcus pretty
much set that up and I'm very EXC I'm
very excited about it now again people
on the internet know this probably a
little bit more than the people in my
church but I'll be meeting again with
Paul Kings North U my first trip to
Europe and Ireland um Marcus had set
this up and and we had a conversation
and recently Paul gave a talk at I don't
need these actually Paul gave a talk at
first things um which has sort of set
the internet really talking and it was
basically something effective against
Christian Civilization now that's not
terribly easy to sort of put together or
what do we mean by that and and it comes
at a moment where where part of the new
Resurgence of Christianity is led by
what some call utilit trads and and they
basically make an argument that well 20
years ago 30 years ago everyone was
feeling that Christianity was sort of
constraining and problematic and so
maybe Christianity should be put to the
side and sort of a secular humanism
should take over but as the power of
Christian institutions has continued to
retreat in our civilization some people
are wondering hey maybe Christianity
wasn't so bad in other words the
argument isn't necessarily whether or
not Christianity is true but how useful
is Christianity in order to have a civil
society and uh Paul was very much not on
that
page
now Aaron Ren who wrote a very
interesting book about life in a
negative world has talked about again
sort of the retreat of Christian
influence the influence of Christian in
institutions in our society he had an
article where he said Donald Trump is
the president for postchristian
America and I I've talked about this
with a number of people and people sort
of try and see it through the narrow
lens of whether or not someone likes or
doesn't like Donald Trump or his
presidency or anything but I'd ask you
to sort of put that aside and ask a
question why was it that in I should
look up the the the campaign okay it was
the front runner for in the 198 88
presidential
campaign and when there was disclosure
that he was having an affair with a
woman
um he dropped out of the race he had to
drop out of the race because it would
just be unseemly for someone to run for
president who couldn't be faithful to
their
wife now whatever you think of Donald
Trump as president or politician marital
faithfulness has never really been much
of a thing for Donald Trump in fact he
he he
recently you know stood trial for an
affair with uh a porn star and and the
difficulty of course is that what's
interesting is is not so is sort of the
question of Standards where why in 1988
would it be Unthinkable for one of the
major parties to have a
politician who had an extramarital
affair and it was known now presidents
have had lots of extra material Affairs
in history John F Kennedy um
FDR but but the country sort of had a
different standard about it and those
standards have changed and so it leads
one to say well what exactly is the
standard and where do our standards come
from is this a decline of Christian
civilization is it a is it a good thing
that we know about the president's
Mistresses or is it a bad thing or maybe
we shouldn't elect people who can't be
faithful to their
spouses now now this whole thing has has
caused a rather remarkable change in
public conversations with respect to
Christianity some of the old new
atheists you know are basically asking
this question in public that you know
maybe instead of Faith being a mind
virus or a version of mental illness
it's actually a necessary part of free
and Civil Society that's sort of the
utilit trat argument now now Paul Kings
North isn't having anything of it he is
saying no if you're you shouldn't be a
Christian because it's sort of help
Society the reason to be a Christian is
because you believe it and it's true and
it's the right thing to do now Paul
himself is a convert he has a very
interesting story he was raised you know
pretty much secular you know Church of
England was just sort of around but then
he had a career as a writer and and
known for an environmentalist and he he
tried wiah and a variety of other
neopagan religions but eventually he
became an Orthodox Christian and
worships at a Romanian Orthodox
Monastery not too far from his farm in
Ireland and in fact when I traveled to
Ireland he invited me to attend um
worship at at his um at his church and I
fully intend to do so I'm really looking
forward to it I've personally never been
to an Eastern Orthodox worship service
but his his conversion sort of caused a
stir because he was sort of imagined as
as a radical and and he had a public
name for certain things and then
suddenly to become a Christian everybody
imagined that the whole sweep was away
from Christianity and here now people
that you would never have imagined
becoming Christians are and and not just
sort
of fuzzy Christians or perennials who
make fond noises about Christianity but
in some ways really crunchy Christians
part of a a very traditional and
conservative um
denomination and so we're doing some
emailing back and forth preparing for
this and you know he said yeah I know my
speech caused a lot of stir but really
as a Christian I'm just sort of publicly
of course but just trying to sort out
how should we live in this technological
World As a Christian and that's exactly
the kind of question that you know if I
were his priest um and it's exactly the
kind of question that I want all of the
people that in my church or anybody who
listens to my YouTube channel who
identifies as a Christian and believes
to be a Christian to ask that question
how should Christians live in the world
today it's a vital question it's not a
new question in fact one of the things
that being a little older that I am now
is that there are today of a lot of what
I saw happening sort of in the 70s and
80s Francis schaer of course wrote a
book how should we then live and and for
inst Schaefer was going through a lot of
the same kinds of questions and
issues that people are today even though
again in a rather different cultural
setting as I said before someone who had
had in his third
marriage you know commonly known affairs
with all kinds of women would not be
considered a suitable candidate for
president for any either political party
and now it's just sort of like doesn't
matter and Dallas Willard you know wrote
a really fine book uh Dallas Willard
started this movement where they were
bringing in a lot of Roman Catholic and
Orthodox spiritual practices into
Protestant Christians Dallas Willard who
was raised a Baptist taught at um
philosophy at USC you know when he
writes his book The Divine
conspiracy basically ask asking this
question what does the sermon in the
mount mean what how should Christians
live
today now we've been going making our
way through the Gospel of Luke and we've
come to chapter
6 on one of those days Jesus went out to
a mountain side to pray and spent the
night praying to God now now mountains
aren't just like sort of places with
greater elevation they have symbolic
significance and of course Moses went up
on Mount Si and Jesus went out into
desolation desolated places to pray so
now Jesus is up on the top of a mountain
he's going to come down from the
mountain similar to how Moses came down
from the mountain and Jesus is going to
do some things after praying being with
the father and so there's all of this
symbolic meaning going on underneath the
text when morning came he called his
disciples to him and chose 12 of them
whom he also designated Apostles these
are the ones that are going to be
authoritatively set out empowered
commissioned to to multiply jesus'
Ministry out into the
world Simon who we met before whom he
called Peter his brother Andrew James
and John those are the ones we saw last
week by the side of the Sea of Galilee
Phillip Bartholomew Matthew Thomas James
son of alfus Simon who was called the
Zealot Judas son of James and Judas a
scariot who became a traitor
now what's to come now is really a
sermon very similar to what we find in
the gospel of Matthew often called The
Sermon on the Mount and sort of the
mountain functions in both ways but
instead of Jesus being on the mountain
delivering the sermon in Matthew you
know that's sort of the Lord gives the
law from the top of the mountain now
Jesus comes down from the mountain sort
of like Moses and delivers the new law
as it were the New Covenant
um now both sermons are probably um I'm
not saying that Jesus didn't say them as
such but these likely were part of what
Jesus would repeat when he would go to
synagogues and he would preach out in
the open air the themes were all there
and so well here's here's the sermon on
the plane as they call it
now he went down with them so the the
disciples meet him and again if you the
book of Exodus the elders go up and meet
Moses on the mountain and have this
vision of God and they come down and
they're supposed to of course lead the
people together with Moses and and so
you have sort of a
recapitulation of that whole thing so
they went down and stood on a level
place so now they're among the people
and a large crowd of his disciples was
there and a great number of people from
all over Judea Jerusalem and from the
coastal region around Ty and siden so
this again looking back at Exodus this
is sort of a mixed multitude you've got
people who are descendants of ancient
Israel you've got people who are are
Gentiles and probably a mixture of just
about everything and now he's he's on
the
plane who had come to hear him and to be
healed of their diseases we talked about
the healing last week those troubled by
imp impure spir Spirits were cured and
the people all tried to touch him
because power was coming out from him
and healing them all so just it's an
amazing scene happening now it's
interesting too The Details Matter
looking at his disciples this is what he
tells his disciples with the crowd
overhearing and it said a large number
of disciples well what did that mean
well the 12 are sort of authorized
elevated and of course the the number 12
is not incidental it's again a
recapitulation of the 12 tribes of
Israel now Jesus has the 12
apostles um as sort of new Sons of Jacob
new Sons of of Israel and he looks at
his disciples and he says blessed are
you who are poor for yours is the
kingdom of God blessed are you who
hunger now for you will be satisfied
blessed are you who weep now for you
will laugh blessed are you when people
hate you when they exclude you and
insult you and reject your name as evil
because of the son of man and again he's
used that title son of man to refer to
himself rejoice in that day and leap for
Joy because great is your reward in
heaven for that is how their ancestors
treated the prophets so again he's
taking his disciples and he's sort of
saying you're you my disciples are like
prophets to Israel like the prophets
were of old to the Kings and you'll see
that in the book of Acts when it's a
very important thing that the Apostle
Paul will appear before Kings at the end
of the book of
Acts now some of you will recognize this
and say well this sounds like what's in
Matthew on The Sermon on the Mount these
are be
attitudes and and people really tend to
like these in the in the gospel of
Matthew because that they're striking
and they seem beautiful and
well I treated them a couple of years
ago their their beauty is partially
because they're
unexpected now now Beatitudes are a
fairly
well-known literary device that you can
find in the Old Testament especially in
the Book of Psalms and of Proverbs and
generally speaking Beatitudes go like
this blessed is the man who walks not in
the counsel of the wicked nor stands in
the way of Sinners nor sits in the seat
of scoffers blessed if he is he whose
transgression is Forgiven whose sin is
covered blessed is the man whom the Lord
imputes no iniquity and who in whose
Spirit there is no
deceit now I've talked before about
common religion and and common religion
basically goes like this if you do good
things good things will happen either
they'll happen sort of naturally in the
process of things or they'll happen as a
gift from God a little bit more
interventionist that's where we get sort
of God number one and God number two and
and Beatitudes are basically kind of
exhortations and statements that
say we could have very secular
biological medical Beatitudes blessed
are you who eat well and exercise for
you will enjoy good health and live a
long life it's very much a natural
consequence we could have a more
religious one and say blessed are you
who go to church regularly and who who
who practice discipline and giving who
tith give your tithes and offerings to
the Lord and who are generous to the
poor for the Lord will reward you this
is the kind of beatitude that is in the
Book of Psalms and in the Book of
Proverbs and this is what we
expect this is not the kind of thing
Jesus is saying and again what what
always strikes me when I hear people
sort of read these as devotions is I
think do you understand how
ironic ironic isn't quite the world
right word how I talked about aoria
before how
disruptive these Beatitudes are the
thing is here in the Gospel of Luke
they're even in a sense cranked up a
little
higher than in the gospel of Matthew as
I said common religion the payoff is
expected in this world eat well exercise
get enough sleep see your doctor you
should be healthy and enjoy good health
in a long life blessed are you who do
this that's a normal beatitude a
religious beatitude live a Pious life
your children will be blessed by your
sobriety your Thrift your frugality and
you will live secure in old age ble um
blessed with wealth savings fruitfulness
Etc but again there's sort of a there
there's sort of
a are these commands are these
invitations it's a little ambiguous
exactly about how these work now Jesus
very much locates the reward for current
hardships into a future time and into a
Heavenly realm so blessed are you who
weep now for you will laugh rejoice in
that day and leap for Joy because great
is reward in heaven blessed are you who
hunger now for you will be satisfied now
future he Heaven it's very clear in
these Beatitudes and and this really
disturbs some people I've been watching
Jordan
Peterson's um gospel seminar on The
Daily wire and it's very interesting how
people are anxious about a dualism okay
how
exactly where they're very they're very
concerned because they've seen people
take these kinds of things and their
lives have been disrupted now obviously
it's a little difficult to um look into
the future or to the next life and see
well did their bets pay
off now all of these are positive and
you'll notice in the Beatitudes in The
Sermon on the Mount that blessed are
blessed are blessed are now in the
sermon on the on the plane you get woes
which especially for us are like well
now Jesus is getting negative and woes
are another Old Testament literary
device that are warnings and again
there's a degree of ambiguity they're
both talking to people who sort of find
them themselves in this situation and
they're talking to people to sort of
avoid finding yourself in this
situation um are these commands are we
to actively seek out being poor hungry
unhappy I didn't read it sorry woe to
you who are rich now for you have
already received your comfort so is
there judgment for the rich woe to you
who are wellfed now for you will go
hungry woe to you who laugh now for you
will mourn and weep woe to you when
everybody speaks well of you for that is
how their ancestors treated the false
prophet so other words disciples who are
this way will be like prophets in Israel
that God
rewarded disciples who are this way
against but what's difficult is that a
lot of the things that he's wo about are
supposed to be the
rewards for doing the right thing the
rewards of the normal
Beatitudes so in other words well I will
I'm going to walk in the way of God and
complete the law so like Abraham and job
and the matriarchs I can be blessed with
wealth and long life and happiness and
children and and Jesus almost says well
if you have those things they're going
to be taken away so maybe I shouldn't
have them maybe I shouldn't seek them
are are these consolations for
involuntary conditions are are they
caused by faithfulness to Jesus or or
caused by a fallen world or both is is
this the life of discipleship is this
how discipleship could be
lived um is there a hierarchy among
disciples are rich Disciples of lower
status than poor disciples are suffering
Disciples of higher status than
comfortable disciples what should this
be and part of what gave Paul King's
North big address um so much friction I
think it's basically comes straight from
the Beatitudes is is is Paul's address
asked these hard questions in a very
pointed way and I think part of the
reason they landed with so so much
resonance
was this is what Jesus
said
now when I go to Ireland you know so
Paul triggered this ancient conversation
that is about the nature of discipleship
and and so when I go to Ireland I'm
going to be staying at a
monastery and it's not the first time
I've stayed at a Catholic Monastery um
again I've had a strange life in the
last seven years that the words of Jesus
triggered later in Christian development
like the third Century an entire
movement of
asceticism that began and they wanted to
obey Jesus and they basically said well
if there's a hierarchy poor Saints are
better Saints than wealthy Saints
suffering Saints are better Saints than
comfortable Saints and so Paul
kingsnorth who has been a successful
writer I'm not saying he's a Healthy Man
by any means but he has sufficient food
he has a good career he gets invited to
go and and speak and and give
prestigious lectures and you know like
many Christians he feels the pinch and
he asked the question should I feel that
pinch what am I to do with the sermon on
the plane and The Sermon on the Mount
now a a lot of people who sort of cheer
for different tribes within Christianity
might say yay to non-protestant because
we didn't throw away the monasteries but
I'd say wait a minute there's some big
ironies in the monastic movement part of
the reason that the Reformation pushed
so hard against it that among common
poor people in Europe at the time there
was a sense that the monasteries were
wealthy and they were Century after
Century after Century people with a lot
of money hearing Jesus thought I'd
better get rid of some of this money now
it happened in the modern realm with
like um with uh Carnegie who gave so
much of his money to libraries you find
these Carnegie libraries and Foundations
they get near to death and he's like I'd
better get rid of this money because you
know how did I get it and I don't want
to be rich when I go up to Peter he
might send me away so I'll give all the
money away and where do they give the
monies away but the monasteries
and so what started out as you know St
Anthony going into a
cave Well everybody's really impressed
by that and just like you know news
about one guy who really did it he must
be a real disciple compared to all those
wobbly ones and um and I want to be a
real disciple too so I'm going to get in
the cave next door and I'm going to get
in the cave next door and the wealthy
people getting anxious about their death
or they start giving money to these poor
these poor monasteries and suddenly the
monasteries are building big buildings
and putting on gold and now all the
monks might have vows of poverty but the
monastery
itself and and you see this going
through monastic movements again and
again so you see monastic movements grow
wealthy and then a new monastic movement
starts and say oh no no those monastic
movements are wealthy we're really going
to be poor and we're going to be poorer
than them and and this went on for about
1,200 years in Christian
history and you know to sort of
understand it there's this great portion
in the movie Forest Gump where you know
after after you know sort of the Fallout
with Jenny Forest starts running because
you know Forest like to run and you know
kind of in the the the the the
strangeness of the movie Forest gum sort
of starts the the jogging fat of the
1970s and you know who is this
mysterious jogger and and and why is he
doing this and what is he doing of
course in Forest Gump he's just running
and and then when he stops the whole
crowd behind him is waiting for a word
on high and of
course the The Stick of the movie is
there's nothing there Forest has no
great word on
high and so the irony of leaving it all
behind is that what actually leaving
leaving it all behind leaves behind it
is Christian
Civilization now the monk who sort of
ended it all is of course Martin Luther
who was an augustinian monk he was you
know had this experience in the woods
was scared to death afraid for his soul
save me Saint and decides to stop his
legal training and get a theological
raining and become a monk and he
couldn't seem to sacrifice enough he
felt to get rid of his sins driving his
Confessor
crazy so well Luther and many others at
that time felt that the monastic
movement was somewhere between the Sham
and corrupt and so all over places that
the Reformation took hold monasteries
were closed and Martin and the other
monks left the monastery and the nuns
left their mon
and well what are we going to do well
then they you know married and Martin
took a nun as well and became a husband
and had children and that's sort of a
big part of the difference between
protestantism and Catholicism for for
many years but then you have the
question is it easier to live without a
family or with a
family um how about the financial
obligations if you're part of a
monastery areer you're dealing with all
of those as a as a as a collective and
and you've got everyone around you who's
encouraging your piety and encouraging
your faith and encouraging
self-sacrifice and but as the monastery
gets wealthier well then the meals are
paid for and health insurance is paid
for and there's always a roof over your
head and I mean you can see that these
things just go round and round and round
and
round so is it easier to be a holy man
on a mountain or in a monastery
or to be a holy man and responsible for
dependence which requires more faith and
so we've been having that conversation
for the last 500 years and we've gotten
to the point that as a culture the same
Dynamics are still there now often it's
let's say people with saffron robes from
from Buddhists that in our culture
walking around every was like oh wow
look at that well you know the the
priests and the nuns those have other
different stories and Western
Civilization but a Buddhist monk ooh ah
they're really committed to poverty and
but they don't have the Sermon on the
Mount post- Protestant secularists are a
little mystified at the anomaly of
aestheticism especially if it isn't
Christian and most post Christians um
the more post-christian we get the more
attractive Christian aestheticism is as
an option for for people who are looking
for the real deal and so I think again
as we get increasingly post-christian
more and more people are going to look
at nuns and Roman Catholic Friars or
Orthodox monastics in the way that many
of them looked sort of as foreign
missionaries from Protestant churches
they're the real Christians because
they're going out into the foreign
Mission field or they're becoming a
pastor and they're going to live in
poverty and you can see that what the
Sermon on the Mount does is it changes
the entire conversation from religion
that said well if you're wealthy you're
certainly favored by God and if you're
poor you must be despised by God Jesus
changes that whole thing
around in our religious moral
framework Paul King's north question and
Francis Schaefer's question lingers out
there well how do we live what's the
best way to
live and and it's sort of an ironic
outcome of affluence
only those who have can give it all away
how about those who don't have in the
first
place many went into monastic orders in
order to escape poverty partly because
at least if you join the
monastery you've got a community that's
going to care for you in your old age
so how do we live Jesus sort of
scrambled the ancient world and changed
it and today we're still sort of left
with the
tensions now we're stuck between the
tensions of command or
invitation and there are many poor
people that we look at and say no
they're not holy at all they're just
poor and others well they're you have to
be voluntarily poor but in order to be
voluntarily poor you have to be in a
situation where you're not necessarily
poor
involuntarily and so we're stuck here
are these invitations
um who exactly is blessed and who are
the warnings going out to now Jesus
himself delivered um many who were
blessed but from their maladies by
healing them we just read well blessed
are you who are ill oh Jesus heal me
well I don't know I don't want to put
you in the woe category if I heal you
now suddenly you're well and happy and
now you get the woes whereas before
you're sick so maybe Jesus shouldn't
have healed them you can see where these
things just kind of go round and round
and round in our
minds
now
Jesus embodies this
himself Jesus establishes a conflicted
unatt unattainable
ideal that has continued to exert a
strong gravitational pull on us as
individuals and on us as a civilization
you can feel it it's in our civilization
it's still
there the monks and the nuns and the
Saints did this and Luther critiqued it
but then
suddenly being a good family member
that's your Christian vocation instead
of the mon Monastery and celibacy and
and so you see though that what Jesus
actually does with these sermons is he
changes the world and now suddenly we
have standards whereby even Forest Gump
going out for a jog we pause and say
there's something there there's
something there maybe I should pay
attention Martin Luther felt the pull
and it drove him out of the monastery
Paul Kings North feels the pull and he's
wrestling with it in public and I think
he's doing us a service to help us all
Wrestle with it in
public anyone who's captured by the
vision of the crucified Christ feels
that
Paul and it doesn't let
go so how do we
live I'm not going to judge those who
followed St Anthony into the
cave and I'm not going to judge Martin
Luther and his wife who left the
monastery it's interesting because you
have the story of the gadan demoniac
where Jesus is on the Gentile side of
the Lake and there's someone who's so
completely possessed by Legion a
thousand evil spirits and Jesus delivers
him and the first thing he says is I
want to follow you take me with you I
don't want to be separated from you ever
I love you so much for the Deliverance
that you've given me please let me pour
out my entire life in gratitude for the
Deliverance that you have offered
me and Jesus doesn't say okay you can be
Apostle number 13 you can be a Gentile
Apostle he doesn't say any of that he
says go to your family go to your town
and tell them what God has done for
you so did he make him rich now he's
able to keep a job now he's able to have
a family he was poor he couldn't even
possess anything because he couldn't
hold
anything now so what's the
point well follow Jesus
he tells the gine
demoniac go be restored to your
family and tell them what God has done
for you he tells the lepers to do
similar things Peter leaves it
all but then when he travels he brings
his
wife he didn't leave his wife Paul says
you know it's kind of nice to not have
marital and familial responsibilities so
I can work devote myself full time to
the work of the Lord
married unmarried wealthy poor I'm not
saying the gravity doesn't go away and
I'm not saying that Jesus doesn't
continue to force us to wrestle with
these
things but Jesus calls each of us to a
life and it might be following a monk
into a cave it might be having the
particular different kind of discipline
of well if you're just one person you
only have you to worry about and you can
live extremely sacrificially well now
you you got children and dependents and
other people who you are responsible to
well you've got that too so you follow
that lamb wherever he goes